i sent word to the boss saying i've held
long enough and mind you
five months before they had declared
tainan a free fire zone
in order to get the population out of
the way
and they they had ordered the people to
leave and then fired shelves every day
to make the people get the message and
leave so the population had evacuated
and we were shelled every day now
we being the downtown area where myself
and the police and the irving command
was in the province chief
this is what i got the medal for
afterwards the medal of merit the second
highest medal in the intelligence world
was because i held my post open for five
months when we were shelled every day in
order to keep this intelligence flowing
this top top agent working
i called the boss on the radio and i
said we've got to get out of here it's
happening today and arvin won't hold i
want a helicopter to come up and get us
and i'd gotten it down to one helicopter
load at that point in one little
briefcase of my last codes and documents
and whatnot
he said i can't do it he said washington
hasn't approved closing payment yet
and i said well i suggest you get on it
i mean he should have you know been on
top of that long before i i didn't
suddenly say this i've been talking to
him three times a day as the situation
had deteriorated i've flown down i
briefed one
um
and this is paul guy is your boss no
this is the regional chief but even
before that
about three weeks before this crunch
time
i flew down i ordered a helicopter and i
flew down to saigon to brief pulgar and
his the top men in the station
on the fact that uh that the south was
going to collapse about the time of
bombing to it i was
uh
my message my reason for going is that
you know the effluvium that they were
putting out of saigon
i that wasn't my business what they were
telling the world or even what they were
telling washington but i wanted to have
a showdown with them and say hey fellas
you know
between you and me
i want you to look me in the face and
admit you know this country is breaking
apart it's about to go
tainan is a targeted place i'll hold my
post open and keep the intelligence
flowing but i want to be sure that
you're not blowing smoke up my backside
i want to make sure we understand each
other and that when the crunch comes the
helicopters will come in and get us now
i flew down to the station landed on the
embassy rooftop went down to the ci
station
polgar was running down the hall and the
other guys sort of stood me off for a
little while and then they said let's go
to lunch we want to hear what you have
to say
they took me to lunch but first they
said let's stop off
for a quick key
and so they took me into the no-name bar
and the no-name bar was just that down
an alley a villa with a fence and you
went in through it and
the living room had been made into a bar
and the dining room area kind of a big
palatial dining room area had had these
little stalls and booths put around the
side without the tables and the
specialty of the house was [ __ ]
and so yeah so we stand at the bar two
of my my bosses two of the top you know
guys
go into the next room and uh and laid
back and girls come to attend to them
and one of the guys is standing beside
me and a girl comes now i'm there trying
to talk to him he's saying yeah yeah i
want to hear what you have to say go
ahead and i'm trying to talk to him
about the fact that the country is
collapsing while she unzips him and
holds him out and starts doing and i'm
sitting there trying to say i mean you
know the madness of the thing i'm trying
to say to myself what's what's the
protocol
when you're when you're down in the
capital to talk to your boss about the
collapse
of a country and the end you know the
united states first
total defeat
and your life and other people's lives
are in danger and your boss is getting a
[ __ ] you know are you supposed to
smile in his face and and encourage him
and you know come on and help him along
or should you you know look off at the
bar and pretend it's not happening until
he's finished you know what's what
nobody had ever taught me in marine
corps training or cia training what the
protocol for that was he still
carrying on his conversation to a point
eventually his eyes glazed over and he
kind of faded away i went and sat out in
the
anteroom outside until they were
finished and then they were saying you
go ahead there hadn't been enough girls
i guess and so you know you go ahead
we'll wait we'll have a beer and now
come on you know we got to talk so we
went to lunch and then afterwards as
we're going back to the embassy they
want to drop me off so i can have mine
and i you know to hell with it and so i
go back to the embassy and fly back to
attain in
what they had said to me is yeah yeah
yeah yeah things are not as bad as you
think but we understand your position
you're up there on the front line and
you probably feel the pressure we really
admire you guys we really admire you
guys for your guts and sticking it out
up there don't worry when the crunch
comes you know we'll come and get you
don't worry a minute you know
so then the crunch comes and my boss
says that they haven't decided to
evacuate us yet